ils ignorent encore que c'est le prix de
leur peur à cet instant une
communication radio informe les soldats
qu'une colonne de la guerill a été
détectée par un avion espion elle fait
mouvement dans la jungle à 3 km environ
c'était le 23 février 2002 ici sur cette
route Ingrid béoncour était enlevé par
les FARC regardez ce sont ces
terroristes qui sont responsables de
l'enlèvement d'Ingrid ça s'est passé à
cet endroit même et vous voyez là-haut
dans lacord d'IER c'est là que les
principaux chefs de l'organisation ont
établit les campements c'est là qu'il
gardent leurs otages
Age en Colombie c'est marché de jour
comme de nuit à l'époque de l'enlèvement
d'Ingrid iici c'était Farland un
territoire grand comme la Suisse
entièrement géré par la Guera
aujourd'hui c'est ça la force combinée
Oméga 20000 hommes appartenant aux TR
armes infanterie marine aviation un
budget de plus d'un million d'euros par
jour assuré en grande partie par lesat
États-Unis si l'étatmajor a
exceptionnellement accepté la présence
d'un journaliste étranger c'est avec une
intention prouver que les jours de ceux
qu'ils ont rebaptisé les
narcoterroristes sont désormais
compter la base secrète de l'arandia au
confin de l'Amazonie le colonel Herman
patakiva est chargé de centraliser le
renseignement d'encourager les
désertions massives chez les guerrier
Ros et accessoirement de supporter le
moral des troupes c'est une balle un
combat contre les fararc et vous
continuez
oui j'ai l'esprit
combattif tu Lutes pour la patrie oui
bien sûr contre les narcotrafiquants
c'est bien la spécialité du colonel ce
sont les opérations psychologiques dans
ces paquets qu'il embarque à chaque
trajet aérien il y a son arme
favorite la cargaison tu vas la Lancer
partout où les gens peuvent la trouver
sur les hameau le long des routes ou
carrément sur les villages d'accord dès
qu'on survole un endroit où il y a des
gens tu balances
c'est une idée apportée d'irac via les
conseillers militaires américains des
dizaines de milliers de trac qui
appellent à la délation aujourd'hui
c'est rossé ventoura Gomez alias Vilmer
un des chefs des FAR qui est
visé colonel c'est papier qu'on vient de
lancer depuis l'é qu'est-ce que c'est ça
fait partie de nos opérations de
propagande on cherche à Moti la
population civ pour qu'elle nous donne
des informations sur le chef de la
colonne numéro 15 des FARC c'est un
terroriste un narcotrafiquant très
important dans cette zone on offre 80000
dollars à celui qui nous donnera un
renseignement le village de calamar un
des postes les plus reculés de la force
Oméga ici il n'y a pas si longtemps
c'est à la guerria que l'ont versa ses
impôts toute l'histoire d'une région à
réécrire pour le colonel et ses hommes
ce village a été pendant très longtemps
un des fières des FARC ici il y avait
leur Labau de coca et leurs otages il
contrôlent complètement toute cette
région les premières positions des FAR
se situent toujours au portes de la
ville c'est pour cela que le colonel se
rend à l'émitur Radio porter 80 km c'est
assez pour réconforter la troupe mais
surtout se faire entendre de la Guera
bonjour combattants j'adresse un salut
particulier à tous les soldats qui se
trouvent dans cette région coupée du
monde je voudrais leur dire que nous
nous battons pour nos enfants pour la
nouvelle génération c'est vrai que
pendant des années les terroristes des
FARC les narcotrafiquants ont dominé
toute cette zone mais aujourd'hui c'est
nous qui sommes là nous sommes les
représentants de l'État nous sommes ici
pour rétablir la loi l'Empire du Bien et
de l'ordre je voudrais aussi envoyer un
message au guerrier Ros je comprends
votre situation depuis 26 ans combat
contre vous les f mais je m'adresse en
premier lieu au chef au
commandant cessz la lutte elle n'a plus
de sens chaque jour l'état est plus fort
quel sera votre avenir lorsque cette
région ne dépendra plus de la coca où
allez-vous trouver
l'argent la coca le ner de la guerre des
fes ce matin obsèque national à Bogota
et grande émotion sur la base si
policiers ont été tu jours plus tt par
la
GU
an
[Musique]
lace ils sont déterminés à poser des
mines à nous livrer des combats très
durs pour nous empêcher à tout prix
d'éradiquer la coca de la
région à côté du colonel le général
Rocha le commandant en chef de la force
Oméga est bien décidé à en finir avec le
sanctuaire des f ce matin il se rend sur
place avec un premier contingent
le mission renforcer la sécurité des
opérations d'arrachage de la
coca pour les chefs de peleton c'est
l'heure d'un dernier
briefing nous allons êtreort jusqu'à
t nous allons opérer un mouvement tacque
jusqu la
for a été longuement préparée elle n'est
pas dépourvue de risque la veille deux
hélicoptères qui ravitaillaient la zone
d'arrachage ont été pris pour cible par
les
f le général lui-même n'est pas très
rassuré pour des raisons sécurité les
Black HW volent en escadrille en se
couvrant
mutuellement dans l'habitacle quel que
soit l'expérience des uns et des autres
la tension est
perceptible atterrissage dans un champ
de coca seul espace dégagé dans
l'épaisse forêt tropicale c'est le
moment le plus délicat l'artilleur ne
quitte pas des yeux le rideau de
végétation à la moindre alerte au
moindre tir redécollage immédiat tant
pis pour ceux qui ont déjà
débarqué il faut faire vite 15 minutes a
dit le général au-delà les fares auront
le temps de s'organiser on a déjà
commencé au fond parce que plus le temps
passe plus il y a de
risque votre problème c'est les mortiers
ici non oui justement pour éviter ça on
va mettre un deuxième périmètre de
sécurité pour pas qu'il puisse
s'approcher ici c'est grand
non on va mettre quatre bataillons au
moins 1000
hommes gu parce que la Guera n'aime pas
quand vous arrachez la
coca elle aime pas ça c'est son argent
c'est son fond de
commerce il y a moins d'un mois ils
étaient 920 paysans à avoir accepté ce
travail d'arrachage 12 morts et autant
de blessés plus tard
ils ne sont plus que 300 les autres
terrorisés par les attaques au mortiers
des fr tireurs des FAR sont rentrés chez
trava difficile i c'est très dur combien
vous P pour
ça7 par jour par
jour l'équivalent de 10 € ris et
condition de vie compris mais à ce tarif
cel n'incl pas les relations
publi qu'est-ce que c'est
du
la nourriture ça va vous avez à
manger non loin de là les hommes du
colonel bcanra ont fait une intéressante
découverte nous sommes en train de
regrouper 4000 têtes de bétail on les
réquisitionne les autorités compé oncié
deiser troupeau à la
Guer a 2000 qu'on na pas encore récupéré
le bétail qu'on a se trouvait dans ce
coin et nous nous sommes là le problème
c'est qu'il faut parcourir 12 km en
pleine jungle pour rejoindre l'endroit
où deux bataillons vont réceptionner le
troupeau ils ont convoqué des vachers de
la région ce sont eux qui seront chargés
de convoyer le précieux
butin combien de temps vous allez
prendre pour aller jusqu'à Vista hermosa
à peu près ça dépend de la sécurité
colonel la sécurité elle est là non il
n'y a pas de
sécurité colonel si la sécurité est
assurée si les conditions sont bonnes on
les sort en un
jour on va probablement les payer à la
journé ou alors ce qu'on peut faire
c'est leur accorder c tes de
bétail chacun chacun ou encore on leur
donne un cheval ses étri et ou tê
ça va dépendre du commandant qui est
là-bas ils ignorent encore que c'est le
prix de leur peur à cet instant une
communication radio informe les soldats
qu'une colonne de la Guer a été détectée
par un avion espion elle fait mouvement
dans la jungle à 3 km
environ bon d'accord on attend pour voir
ce qui va se passer à
vous les jeunes à bientôt je vous salue
je vous dis bonne
chance
le colonel a l'air soudain pressé de
partir le pilote de l'hélico beaucoup
moins de se
posé
regard regard il est
là finalement il faudra à l'hélicoptère
TR passages à basse altitude pour tester
le feu enemi avant
d'atterrir retour à la base mission
accomplie pour tous c'est le
soulagement même s'il ne s'agit que de
4000 têtes de bétail saisies et de
quelques plans de coca arraché pour le
colonel patakiva c'est une victoire au
moins
psychologique et des victoires il en
faut car après 20 années passées sous le
jou de la Guera c'est la peur qui domine
encore dans les
[Musique]
villages une des missions du colonel
c'est de tenter de rassurer la
population y compris les nombreux
habitants qui qui aujourd'hui souhaite
quitter la
région comment allez-vous et toi petite
comment ça va qu'est-ce qui t'arrive
elle a la fièvre ça va lui passer vous
ça va ça va ça va mais ça me fait peur
ne vous inquiétez pas et eu ce qu'ils
font là c'est pas c'est pas dangereux
non je vais essayer de trouver du
soutien pour vous sortir
d'ici je vais faire les démarches pour
trouver un moyen de transport dès que
j'ai des nouvelles je vous préviens via
la radio part parce que sans la coca il
n'y a plus de travail mais pour le
colonel il est crucial qu'il reste bon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que vous
ne partiez pas qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
créer comme petit business vous qui avez
d'expérience moi vous voulez connaître
mon expérience pardon lui
d'abord on pourrait monter un petit
élevage de cochon ou de
volaille autre moyen de convaincre des
bonnes intention de l'armée la
distribution de friandis un classique
inspiré des Américains colonel vous
allez toujours dans les villages avec
des bonbons dans les poches oui c'est
pour essayer d'adoucir la vie des
Colombiens il n'a pas les moyens de ses
ambition omga c'est 30 million d'euros
mensuel dont seul une infime partie est
dédié au projet civil du colonel
patakiva alors les sucrerie il les paye
de sa poche